[MUSIC PLAYING]
ALEX MONTOYA: Today I'm
going to speak on my journey,
and my journey that has taken
me from Medellin, Colombia
to San Diego, and a lot
of points in between.
And a journey that has included
overcoming adversity, but also
seeing how both technology and
inspiration within technology
has really led me to do
something what I call living
inspired.
And my goal is not for
anyone to quit their job
at the end of day,
but to actually
be more inspired within
their role to really make
their job even more phenomenal.
So you'll see what
I mean by that.
But before I begin, I'm
going to ask each of you
to do me a favor.
I know people are eating and
you've got a plate of food
on your lap.
If you can, set the
food aside for a second.
I'm going to ask
everybody to stand up.
Arise.
Rise to your feet.
OK.
Everybody raise up.
Now if you can, can you
please raise your left arm?
Your left arm.
A couple of you had
to think about it.
I like that.
OK.
Keep it up.
If you can, could you also
please raise your right arm?
Your right arm.
There you go.
Let's wave your hands.
Hey, oh, hey, ho.
Make sure you're awake.
Make sure the blood is flowing.
OK.
Keep 'em up.
Now if you can--
I know we kind of have
some tight space here.
If you can, you also please
raise your right leg?
Your right leg.
There you go.
It's kind of like,
"The Karate Kid" pose.
Right?
There you go.
Awesome.
Go ahead, put it down.
There we go.
That's what we call
a little Google yoga.
You can put the hands down, too.
You're good.
I just wanted somebody
everybody was awake,
was alive, was ready to go.
I'm going to ask you
one more favor, now
that I know that everybody
is fully present.
If you would, please
follow my lead.
[CLAPPING]
Ooh!
There we go.
Go ahead, have a seat.
The reason I do that--
the power clap, or as civil
rights icon Cesar Chavez used
to use with the farm workers--
he called it the si, se puede--
yes, you can clap--
is for this reason.
If I had asked just
one row of you,
or if I had asked just
one section of you
to clap your hands,
to make some noise--
it would have made
pretty minimal impact.
Right?
But by asking all of you
to clap at the same time,
it made more impact.
It made more noise.
We do so much more
when we work together.
We have so much
more of an impact
when we're all working together,
pulling on the same rope,
doing the same clap
at the same time.
We have more of a
thunderous, impactful impact.
So bear that in mind.
In 2015, I had a very nice
job with the San Diego Padres.
Sports is my passion.
Love the Padres as a team, love
the Padres as an organization.
And I decided at that
point to leave my job
within the Community
Relations Department,
because I wanted to do more.
I wanted to try
something different.
I wanted to see
really what it was
like to kind of take
a risk, take a plunge,
be out there on my own.
And really get the aspect
of taking a risk really
for the first time in my life--
of figuring out if
I have ambition,
and if I have a
passion, but I also
have teamwork surrounding
me in my life.
How much more could I,
as an individual, do?
I wanted to see that.
I wanted to really give
that the first test.
Now on the theme
of teamwork, let
me give you a quick example.
Once I left the Padres--
and a lot of people
were surprised.
A lot of people said, you
know, you spent 10 years there.
It's a fantastic job,
wonderful organization.
Is this something you're
sure you want to do?
And I said, you know,
it might sound crazy.
It might sound a
little unorthodox.
But there are times
where you have
to leave your comfort zone
because, that's really
where the greatest growth is--
when you leave
your comfort zone.
I'm sure that this is something
not only that I want to do,
but something that I need to do.
One of my first
speaking engagements
when I decided to become
a full-time writer
and become a full-time
speaker was in Chicago.
I have a friend here
the audience today--
Cort Peters.
Cort, raise your hand.
Wave to the crowd.
Cort and another good
friend of mine named Sean--
the three of us were in Chicago.
And I know that
Googlers travel a lot,
so you guys are familiar with
a lot of different cities
and a lot of different
airports, and how crazy
it can be at the airports.
Well, so we're in Chicago.
It's actually President's
Day weekend of 2017.
And my speaking
engagement was on Friday.
So that gave us the whole
weekend to enjoy the city,
and then on Monday, to fly home.
Now for those of you that
have been in Chicago,
been through Chicago--
you know that the
Chicago Airport--
either one, either Midway or
O'Hare-- that day I was through
Midway--
is not an easy deal.
Especially on a holiday
weekend, especially
on a Monday of a
holiday weekend.
And so I have a personal
habit, a personal routine.
I like to try to
be anywhere that I
need to be at least an
hour early, but especially
the airport, and especially
when you wear prosthetics
and it takes extra
longer to go through TSA
because they need to check
all of your prosthetics.
They need to look
through everything.
They just have you go
in a separate line.
Let me just tell you,
it's just quite a mess.
And so I always make sure that
I'm there an hour minimum,
early.
Well, on that
particular day as me
and my buddies arrived
to the airport--
now their flight was actually
two hours later than mine.
My flight was going to be two
hours departing before them.
And so they said,
OK, let's just all
go to the airport
at the same time.
Let's make sure that we get
there, we get you through TSA,
we get you through
your usual boondoggle
of going through TSA.
But we'll get you there.
Turns out with the usual
Chicago Airport craziness,
with a traffic jam with
the holiday weekend,
and a TSA agent that
wanted to move extra slow--
and actually lectured
me for not arriving
to the airport on time--
in which case I was
telling him dude,
you're not making
me move any faster.
Like, this is crazy.
We realized that I only
had about a half hour
to get through TSA, and
to get through everything
with the luggage.
And by the time we did that,
I had exactly 10 minutes
to catch my flight--
10 minutes.
And mind you, if
you try to go from,
you know, the area where
you have your luggage
and you're trying to
get to your gate I mean,
that's at least a good 10
minute walk for anyone.
For me, probably
a little slower.
So my best friend Cort
says, I've got an idea.
There was a wheelchair nearby.
It was empty.
It was vacated.
Nobody was using it.
Cort's like, I'm going to
wheel you down to your gate.
Take all of our bags,
hold them in your lap.
This is teamwork here.
Sean, I want you to
run up to the gate.
It's almost like we
playing football out
on the asphalt. Sean, go deep.
He was like, Sean,
run to the gate.
Let them know that
we are on the way.
We don't want Alex
to miss his flight.
So I get in the wheelchair.
I could feel Cort, with his
bare white knuckles clenching
against the chair.
And we start racing
down the concourse.
And we're running.
He's running.
He's huffing, he's puffing.
I'm like, fearing for my
life inside the wheelchair.
I can-- what's that?
CORT PETERS: I said
you weren't running.
ALEX MONTOYA: I wasn't running,
but my heart was racing.
And I could see Sean running
side, right alongside of us.
He's getting up to the gate.
There's a point to
the story, I promise.
And, you know, what's
amazing is all the people
on the concourse-- there's just
kind of a universal thing that
whenever they hear
the sound meep-meep--
which is exactly
what we were doing--
people were ducking
out of the way.
And they were ducking
And we were zigging
and we were zagging.
And I just knew
that if we happen
to hit any sort of a speed
bump at all on the wheelchair,
I was going to come flying out
of that chair in an instant.
But fortunately,
that didn't happen.
And my whole thing
was not only did
I want to get an
hour early just to be
able to take care of our
luggage and get to the gate,
I was also hungry.
I wanted some McDonald's.
You know?
And I was like, Cort, don't
we have time for McDonald's?
He's like, no.
We don't have time to eat.
We've got to get
you to the gate.
So we're flying
down the concourse.
We get there.
We arrive with one
minute to spare--
one minute to spare.
And the flight attendant
says, hey, you guys are fine.
Welcome.
Your buddy ran up and told
me you were on the way.
We're probably not going to
take off for another 10 minutes,
so you're good to go.
And I turn around.
I'm amazed.
My heart's still racing.
Cort is huffing and puffing.
Sean is huffing and puffing.
We're gasping.
And I turned to them.
And I said, you
know, you guys still
have a couple of hours
before your flights home.
What are you guys going to do?
And Cort says, eh, we'll
probably go to McDonald's.
So I said, wow.
OK.
Well, that's messed up.
But it's all good.
But it was the teamwork
that got me there.
It was the teamwork
that got me to the gate
and got me obviously
to my flight,
to where I needed to go.
It was those kinds
of experiences
that I wanted to embrace.
It was those kind of
adventures that I wanted now
to be a part of my life.
Because as you will
see, my journey
is far different than the
journey that most people take.
My name is Alex Montoya.
I am the owner of
A-MOtivational Communications.
Ever since that
day three years ago
where I decided to leave my
job and do this full time,
I am an author.
I have published four books.
And I have a fifth
book on the way.
I am a speaker.
I get to travel the country
sharing my experiences
and sharing my thoughts.
I am an immigrant.
I was born in
Medellin, Colombia.
And I am also a triple amputee.
When I was born in 1974,
I had a rare birth defect
that led me to be
born missing both
of my arms and my right leg.
Now the doctors
didn't expect it.
The doctors didn't
anticipate it.
They didn't know
this was coming.
My family didn't
know this was coming.
I had an older brother,
and an older sister.
They were all physically fine.
So this was quite a
shock to my family.
And actually, the message
that the doctors delivered
to my parents was
that they should have
low expectations for my life.
They said, you know,
if your son was
born missing both
of his arms and he
was born missing both of
his legs-- by the way,
we have the Google
Slides available.
Go ahead and put
that first one up.
That's actually a
picture of me shortly--
maybe a year or so after
being born, with my parents
there in Columbia.
And so you can see that I
have a little bit of a stump,
in essence.
But I was primarily born missing
the arms and the right leg.
And the doctors message
was, his adversity in life
will be so great,
and his challenges
will be so great that you should
keep your expectations low.
You should keep your
thoughts low about what
he's going to be able
to accomplish in life.
You see, at that
time Colombia didn't
have a lot of technology.
They didn't have
special education.
They didn't have access
to making prosthetics.
There wasn't really
a whole lot of hope
for people with disabilities.
It's a lot better now, and
there's been a lot of changes,
and there's been a
lot of modernization.
And it's a different world now.
But at that time in 1974, if you
were born with a disability--
if you had a disability--
life was extra challenging.
And some of my first memories
that I can actually recall
are two primary things.
As long as I've been
old enough to remember,
as long as I've been old
enough to formulate memories,
I remember my parents--
and especially my father,
pictured right there--
I remember my father telling me
no matter what the world says,
I don't want you feeling
sorry for yourself.
And no matter what
the world says--
Because he knew.
He knew that once we
went out in public,
people would be looking
at me differently.
People would even
be pointing at us,
and whispering to themselves.
And people would actually come
up to me and come to my family
and say, wow.
I feel sorry for you.
I really feel sorry for you
that you're in this predicament.
And my father said, don't
ever give in to that.
Even though the world
may feel sorry for you,
you can never feel
sorry for yourself.
And his reasoning was this.
He said as long as you have a
strong faith, a strong family,
and a strong education
you can do anything.
You can do anything
at all in this world.
And that was really where the
first idea of teamwork kind of
came into my mind,
or my consciousness.
Because they said you're
going to need a lot of help.
You're going to need assistance.
But you're not going
to need everyone
to do everything for you.
We're going to find a
way to help you to be
able to do things for yourself.
So I remember really as
far back as I can remember,
I remember that was
one of the main lessons
that my father taught me.
The other thing
that I remember was
that every single morning
when my father would wake up,
the first thing that he would
do is not look out the window
and check the weather--
which really, he needed to
do because he was a traveling
salesman.
He didn't check
the news headlines.
He didn't check the
family finances.
You want to know the very first
thing that my father would
do every single morning?
He would wake up, he would
thank God for a new day,
and he would crank up the music.
He would crank up the
music and start singing,
and start dancing,
and start flooding
our household with music.
And it drove my mom nuts,
because we're not exactly
morning people in my household.
And she would say, what
the heck are you doing?
And he would say, we're going
to make this day a great one.
We're going to make
this day a happy one.
We are going to set the tone.
And we're going to do
something that inspires us,
and something we're
passionate about.
One of his main
passions was music,
so he would flood the household
with music every single day.
So those were the two
main memories that I had.
Now when I was four years old,
my life took a radical change.
An organization here
in the United States
called the Shriners Hospitals
offered the chance for me
to move from Colombia,
and move to the States
in order to receive medical
help and my education.
The Shriners, for those
that may not know--
an organization that takes kids
from Central America, Latin
America, Mexico--
and if they have
either orthopedic needs
or are burn victims,
they will bring them
to this country
for free and take
care of all of
their medical needs
as long as they have a need and
irrespective of financial need,
all the way up to age 18.
And so they made an
offer to my family.
I already had some family
living in the States,
and living in San Diego.
My mom's sister,
my aunt, lived here
in San Diego with her
husband and their kids.
And so we already
had family built in.
And so the offer was
extended-- why don't you
move Alex to the US?
We'll take care of his needs.
He'll go to school.
He'll get the
education, and really
receive the life that he
would not have in Colombia.
And so my family
knew that that was
a brand new opportunity for us.
I remember my father
sitting me down the night
before I left for the States.
And he said this.
He said, I hope you realize that
this is a once in a lifetime
opportunity.
God has shone his
grace on us, and you
have a wonderful, marvelous,
incredible opportunity
to go to the US,
receive your education,
receive prosthetics,
receive artificial limbs,
and really start your
life over, and to prove
all those doctors and
all those people wrong,
that you can succeed
just like anyone else.
It was pretty heady stuff
for a four-year-old to hear.
But I needed to hear it.
And he said, you have two main
missions when you go to the US.
He said number one, I
want you to study as hard
as you possibly can and
pursue a quality education,
passionately.
And he said number two, I want
you to inspire other people.
I want you to show
people what is possible.
And again, as a four
year old, I didn't really
fully know what that meant.
I was just looking forward
to coming to the States,
going to Disneyland
for the first time,
going to McDonald's.
I have an obsession
with McDonald's.
You know, I was just
really looking forward
to all those things.
And my father knew that I had
a far more important mission
on this journey.
Next slide.
So the first thing that
happened when I moved to the US
was I received my prosthetics.
The Shriners received
my prosthetics,
and I'd love to explain to you
and show you how they work.
If you notice on
the picture there,
I wear a strap
harness that actually
is attached to my back.
And the strap harness
is connected to a series
of cables on my arms.
And hopefully
everyone here can see.
And whichever way I
move my shoulder--
and you can see there
in the picture, the way
they're connected to me.
Whichever way I move my shoulder
will actually pull on the cable
to make the hook itself move.
So even if my arm
is all the way out--
even if my arm is all
the way out past me,
I need to be able
to move it inwards
in order for the strap harness
to pull on the right cable.
The cable will
pull on the thumb,
and the thumb itself
will pull on the hook.
And that's just
what I call them.
It's just my hooks.
And whichever way I move
will trigger everything else.
So if I move my
shoulder downwards,
it'll move a different set of
cables on my elbow in order
for the elbow to move.
And that's what allows the
elbow up and down motion.
And that's what allows for the
prosthetic itself to operate.
My leg is actually a
prosthetic hydraulic knee.
So in other words, because
I don't have the same heel
to toe ratio as most
people, whenever I step down
I actually activate a hydraulic
knee that lifts me up.
And it's connected to
me through a waist belt.
And it remains connected
to me all day long.
I take my arms and
leg off at night.
I put them on in the
morning, very easily.
I slip into them just like
an old pair of slippers.
But they are on me
as long as I'm awake,
all day long, all day strong.
And I learned a couple
of things through that.
I learned number one, the
importance of connectivity.
I knew that I needed my
straps to be connected
to my cable, my
cable to be connected
to my hook, the hook itself to
be activated through the thumb.
I needed for the hydraulic
knee to stay activated and stay
connected to the
other parts of my leg,
in order for me to walk.
I knew that prosthetics
were all about connectivity.
I knew that all of
these things connected
allowed me to move, and
walk, and talk, and live
a normal life.
But I also saw that
there was a higher
level, or a different
level of connectedness
that I had to embrace.
First of all, there is
the technology aspect.
Obviously, I had to embrace
all of the technology
that I was wearing.
And whereas most people would
see me and say, wow, poor guy--
he has prosthetics--
I would look
at it as, this is fantastic.
Whereas before I
didn't have anything,
and I couldn't hold anything,
and I couldn't grab anything.
All of a sudden you're
giving me prosthetics
that are allowing me to
hold, and grab, and grab
food, and grab a pen, and be
able to operate and function.
This is great.
This is fantastic.
For me, this is freedom.
But I also learned that
it wasn't necessarily
an easy freedom.
There were a lot of challenges.
One of my first
obstacles was learning
how to put on a t-shirt.
And just as a side note,
a lot of the things that I
had to learn how
to do, maybe you
might take them for granted.
Because there are
things that you've
done every single day
of your life with great,
tremendous ease.
And I just want to say, never
take things for granted.
Never take even the easiest,
simplest thing for granted.
Because not all of us can do
those things, necessarily.
Not all of us can necessarily
have an easy pathway
to learning those.
Never take even the
simplest things for granted.
Show gratitude in all things.
And I remember my
aunt-- remember,
my mom's sister who really
became like a second mom
to me--
the very first time she
saw me struggling putting
on a t-shirt, and struggling to
learn how to put my prosthetic
arms through the arm
holes on the shirt--
she said, you know,
I can help you
and we would get your
shirt on right away.
Or I can teach you how to do
this, and help you find a way
to do this so that you can
put your own shirt on forever.
And we learned, and we developed
a system where we said let's
just put one prosthetic
arm through one
hole, the next prosthetic
arm through the next hole,
my big, fat head through
the hole of the head.
And then, of
course, I need to be
able to grab onto to the
shirt itself, pull it down.
But for me, that was
a learning process.
That was an example of learning
the keys of determination.
I saw that I needed to
embrace being determined,
because things just weren't
going to be as easy for me.
And then finally,
the third thing
was I needed to learn how--
no matter what in each
aspect of my life--
I needed to be
self-motivated and self
inspired to be able to overcome
these sorts of obstacles.
The greatest and most
immediate example of that
was my very first summer camp.
I attended a camp in
the state of Arizona.
I was very excited.
I was dressed far
different than today.
I had on a t-shirt and shorts--
you know, the kind of thing
that you would normally
wear to a camp.
So you could see my prosthetics
very clearly, and very easily.
And I was very impressed that
when the school bus pulled up
to the campsite and we were
ready to jump off the bus
and go to the camp,
I was very impressed
that the camp director
was actually right there
to greet us and to say hello.
Imagine my surprise when
I stepped off the bus
and I saw him looking at me.
And I saw him looking
at my prosthetic arms.
at my prosthetic leg.
And he pauses, and he looks
at me square in the eye,
and he says, wow.
I wish you weren't here.
And I said, why?
And he goes, well, you
obviously got a lot going on.
You're dealing with a
whole lot going on here.
You're probably going
to need a lot of help.
You're going to need
a lot of assistance.
You may even fall
and sue our campsite.
I just wish you weren't here.
I wish you were
at some other camp
for some other kind of kids.
And that was my first
taste of really wanting
to prove someone wrong.
That was my first taste of
being inspired and saying,
you know what?
I understand why you
have those views.
Because I know by now
that we're all just
kind of a composite of our
experiences and our ambitions.
And that's really just
what his viewpoint was.
His only encounters
with disabled people--
if he had any at all--
were that they
were somebody that
needed a lot of
help, somebody that
needed a lot of assistance.
He looked at me
from my limitations
instead of my potential.
And I was inspired
to prove him wrong.
Now contrast that with another
incident, just a short time
later, where I joined
some friends of mine
on the playground for
the very first time.
And I noticed that
they were all going
to frolic and have fun
and have a good time
at this beautiful, shiny,
metallic thing called
the monkey bars--
which for me, was a
brand new experience.
How many here used to
play on the monkey bars
when you were kids?
I'm just curious.
OK.
How many still play
on the monkey bars?
OK, good.
All right.
You're honest.
I appreciate that.
Well for me, it was a
brand new experience.
And I went out with
about 10 of my friends.
And they looked at me.
And I remember about half of
them looked at the monkey bars
and they said, Alex, are you
sure you want to do this?
Like, we don't
know if the straps
and the cables on your
arms can suspend you
in the air like that.
We don't know if you're
even able to climb up
to the monkey bars.
This is probably
not a good idea.
not a good activity.
You should probably
sit this one out.
And then I had another
group of friends--
about five other friends--
that said, you know what?
If you want to get on the
monkey bars, let's find a way.
What if we took your
hooks and we clamped them
onto the rungs of the
ladder, and we had
you climb one rung at a time?
And what if we take your
good leg-- your left leg--
and we had you put all
your weight on there
and just kind of drag
your prosthetic leg up?
And I liked their
thinking a lot better.
Because I think
the words what if
are the greatest words
in the English language.
I think when you come
from a point of what
if, you come from a
point of potential.
You come from a point of
exploring possibilities.
And so I said, you know what?
I think you're right.
What if we do that?
So I said, I'm
going to try this.
And my friends even said, look.
If you fall down, we're
going to laugh at you.
But we'll help you up.
You know, we'll find a way.
And so they said,
let's take your hooks.
Let's clamp them onto
the rungs of the ladder.
And so I climbed, and I climbed,
and I climbed, and I climbed.
And they said, let's take a
good leg-- your left leg--
and let's put all
the weight on there.
Let's kind of drag
your prosthetic leg up.
So I'm climbing, and I'm
climbing, and I'm climbing,
and I'm climbing.
And by now, this is
like an OMG moment.
Like, OMG, this is happening.
This is the reality now.
And by that point,
all the kids--
all the kids were--
the ones that said that I could
and the ones that said that I
couldn't-- they're yelling
for me, they're cheering,
they're whistling.
Girls are inviting me to prom.
I mean, it was just crazy.
So I'm climbing, and I'm
climbing, and I'm climbing,
and I'm climbing.
And I realized that I've spent
so much focus and so much
time on thinking about
what it took to get up
to the top of the monkey bars--
I hadn't thought about
what it was going to take
to get across the monkey bars.
And how many times
in life do we think
about a certain
ambition that we have,
or a certain project,
or a certain plan,
and then we realize that
everything has gone sideways
and we have to just
adapt our life.
And so I quickly
had to think, OK.
If I want to get
across the monkey bars,
I needed to raise
my strap harness--
as you see there--
raise it just a
little bit higher.
And so that way, I can
raise my arms higher
and start climbing across, and
across, and across, and across,
and across.
And I reached about the halfway
point when all of a sudden I
heard the worst
sound that you'd want
to hear at that moment, which
was [IMITATES SCHOOL BELL]..
What do you think that was?
The school bell.
And all of a sudden
I'm still up there,
and all my friends are below me.
And they scattered.
I was like Moses
parting the Red Sea.
Because they ran to the
left, they ran to the right,
they all ran away.
And I'm still up on the
monkey bars by myself.
And it took about five
minutes for my teacher
to realize that I
wasn't in class.
And she comes out and she says,
"Alejandro Montoya Gonzalez--"
And you know you're in trouble
when they say all three names.
She said, "Alejandro Montoya
Gonzales, what are you doing?"
And I said, "Hey.
I'm just hanging out.
How about you?"
And she laughed.
But she helps me down.
But that incident-- both
combined with the incident
in camp and the incident
on the monkey bars--
topped the three key
things that really I've
carried through with me
for the rest of my life.
Number one, once
again, it taught me
the importance of technology.
It taught me how I had to
trust that my arms were
built in the right way.
I had to trust that the
strap harness and the cables
weren't going to let me down.
I had the trust that I had a
good, strong leg that could
help me in getting up there.
I had the trust
the technology that
was on me, and that
was a part of me,
could help me to be able
to do something new--
a new activity like this--
whether it was be at the camp,
or be on the monkey bar itself.
And then, of course,
the second aspect
was I once again saw the
importance of determination.
When life, or actual
people tell you
that you can't do
something, how determined
are you to prove them wrong?
How determined are
you to show people
that their expectations
are too low?
When people tell you that
adversity is too strong
and the odds are too great, how
determined are you to succeed?
How determined are you to push
forward against all adversity?
Because I'm not the only
one that has adversity.
Every single person does.
Even people who you think
have so-called perfect lives
have adversity.
It's part of our DNA.
It's part of our fiber.
It's part of everything
that goes on.
We all have a level of
adversity in our lives.
But each one of us responds
to it in a different way.
How determined are you to
overcome those obstacles?
And then finally, number three--
when I was up there and
I was at the monkey bars
and I was hanging
out by myself, I
felt like I was the only
person left on Earth.
I mean, everybody cleared out.
There will be times within
your journey, Googlers,
and within your career path or
even a project or assignment
that you're working on--
you may feel like you're alone.
You may feel like
people don't understand
your journey, or the
things that you go through,
or the places that you've been,
or the pathway that you've
taken.
You may feel like there are
times where you are alone
in your mission.
And that is when
I want to remind
you to just keep hanging on.
Just keep believing in yourself.
Just keep believing in your
conviction, and in your ideals.
And just like my father told
me, and continued to tell me
whenever I would call home--
don't feel sorry for yourself.
Know that if you have a strong
faith, a strong family--
which also includes
strong friends--
a strong education,
you can do anything.
You can overcome anything.
And you will inspire
other people.
And I saw that those were going
to be lessons that continued
to influence me, guide me,
carry me, really motivate me
all the way through.
It fueled me to
always tell myself
I'm not just going to
do the bare minimum.
I'm going to make
sure that I try
to make my dreams come true to
the greatest extent possible.
When I chose my
place of college,
I chose a pretty
challenging school--
the University of Notre Dame.
Go, Irish.
When I chose my
career path, I chose
to go into professional sports--
not only because I had
a passion for sports,
but because a lot
of people said,
well, everyone wants
to get into sports.
There's no way you'll
ever get a job in sports.
There are millions of people
out there getting into sports.
And that motivated me
to try even harder.
And because of that,
I was able to spend
10 years working in sports
for the San Diego Padres.
One of my other
passions was writing.
I've always been a
very passionate writer.
And it fueled me
and it motivated
me to be able to write, and
to start expressing my story
and expressing my journey.
Another passion of mine and
another mission that I took on
was marathon running.
Next slide.
I know that Google is
celebrating its 20 year
anniversary.
Well, you know what else
happened 20 years ago?
The Rock and Roll
Marathon series
began 20 years ago, actually
right here in San Diego.
And for me, I wanted
to prove to people
that even a guy on one leg
could complete a marathon.
Even the guy with a disability
could do something as arduous,
as grueling, as grinding
as be on a marathon,
and be on a marathon relay
team-- which is what I did.
Now the very first
marathon in San Diego,
or the very first Rock
and Roll Marathon--
which was located and
created here in San Diego--
was in 1998.
And it was actually
at Balboa Stadium,
which is next to San Diego
High School, downtown.
That's my alma mater.
I went to San Diego High.
So quick story here--
because I went to San Diego
High and I knew the layout
of the place, and I knew the
whole layout of where they
would have the
post-race concert--
How many here have been
involved in marathons?
Anybody?
OK.
A few of you.
Good.
Anybody that's been involved
in the Rock and Roll Marathon
will know that one of the
greatest aspects of that race
is they have a really
cool concert as
soon as the race ends.
Well, the concert that year was
at Balboa Stadium, right next
San Diego High.
And the headliner was
Huey Lewis and the News--
a famous group, of course,
from the '80s and '90s.
And so I, knowing the
layout as well as I did--
I snuck backstage.
I snuck into the buffet area--
again, obsessed with food.
And I walked up to Huey Lewis.
Let's go back to
that other slide.
I walked up to Huey Lewis.
And Huey Lewis looks at me,
and he looks at my prosthetics.
And his first words are,
"Hey, you have two of those."
And I said, "Yeah.
Why don't you give me
two of those hot dogs?"
And he did.
He put two hot dogs on my plate.
So I could actually say that I
was served food by a rock star.
Sometimes what the
world might view
as a hindrance or a
limitation or something bad,
can actually lead
to great adventures
and to great and
wonderful times.
I think it's fair
to say I probably
wouldn't have met Huey
Lewis and the News,
or been as brazen
about it, unless I
had this very
interesting topic to be
able to talk to Huey about.
It's really led me to have
some very great experiences,
and inspirations, and
things that have really
proven to people that life is
all about how you look at it--
focusing to choose
on what you have
instead of what you are missing.
I'll finish with this.
I'll finish with
one final story.
Circling back to when I decided
to turn this into a full-time
business, and be a
full time writer,
and be a full time speaker--
one of my other first
speaking engagements
aside from the one in
Chicago was actually
at a school in
downtown San Diego
called The Monarch School.
And for those that might not
be familiar with The Monarch
School--
it is this school
exclusively dedicated
to kids who are homeless.
And I remember
when I was invited
to speak at that school--
I remember thinking, wow.
I guess part of
doing this full-time
and speaking and
writing full-time
is going to places that
I might not even feel
all that confident in going to.
And the reason I
didn't feel confident
is because I felt that no matter
how many obstacles I have,
and no matter how many
adversities I have,
I'm fortunate to know that
I have a roof over my head
at the end of the day.
And I didn't know what I
could say that could possibly
inspire the kids at
that school, given
the circumstances they're in.
But I remembered what
my father told me.
And I actually called home
and talked to him about it.
And he said, look.
Your mission is to continue
to live life with passion,
pursue your education with
passion, and inspire people.
You need to go and
give your message,
and inspire those kids.
And so I did.
I went to the Monarch School
and I spoke to the students.
And I especially
emphasized the importance
of not giving in
to your obstacles,
not giving in to your
hurdles, never giving
up, and just trusting that
good things would be ahead.
But I still walked out of that
school not feeling too great.
Because again, I didn't
feel like the things
that I had overcome
necessarily measured up
to what they were overcoming.
About a week later
after my talk,
I'm in downtown San Diego.
It's where I live.
It's where I run my business.
And I actually run my business
out of the downtown San Diego
Library--
which if you haven't been to the
library down there, please do.
It's a marvelous place.
And a little girl approaches me.
And she says, "Mr.
Alex, Mr. Alex."
And I look and I say, "Yes?"
And she says, "Mr. Alex,
I have something for you."
And I say, "What could
you possibly have?"
And she kneels down, and she
reaches into her backpack.
And she says, "I
made you a picture."
I said, "You made me a picture?"
My friend Cort here is going to
show you this beautiful picture
that she made,
that I had framed.
And it says, Alex
Montoya, big and strong.
And I said, "You
made that for me?"
And I thought about it.
And I said, "Wait a minute.
It's like, 12:00 right now.
Why aren't you in school?"
And she says, "Well,
we're actually
given an hour to go home,
check on our families,
and make sure everything
is OK with our families.
And then we have to go
back to our school."
Thank you, sir.
And she says, "I made this
specifically for you."
And I was blown away.
And I said, "Thank
you so, so much."
But I was curious.
I said, "So you liked my talk.
What was it about my
talk that you liked?"
And she says,
"Well, I'm homeless.
And your message to us was
all about never giving up.
Your message was
to us about if we
are inspired within our lives
to do more and to be more,
then no matter what else we
have going on in our life
we can overcome it.
That we can't give
in to the thoughts
and negativities and all the
challenges we have going on.
That I have to keep
pushing and moving forward.
That I can give up on life."
She said, "I thank you, because
that really inspired me."
And it blew me away.
It blew me away.
Because it taught me that
our mission in life--
all of us-- is to
inspire others.
Our mission is to take
whatever adversities,
whatever challenges, whatever
things go wrong, whatever
things aren't perfect--
and grow from them,
and learn from them,
and be determined by them.
And to take the
things that we have--
so in my case it's having
prosthetics, and having
a strong faith, and a strong
education, and a strong support
system--
and making the most
out of those things
to be able to inspire others.
It is our mission and our
role to inspire other people.
Now Google, as a company,
often times will do that.
Let's say when the home page is
changed on the search engine--
sometimes you honor
certain causes or leaders
or civil rights leaders.
That's a very inspiring thing.
But only you know within your
roles and within your jobs
how exactly you can even
inspire even more people--
how you can inspire the
greater world out there.
I urge you-- urge you to
look for a way every day,
not just to get through the
day, not just to get through
the deadlines and the work
and the meetings and all those
things that we have--
all those things that are
part of our responsibilities.
I urge you to not just
get through those.
I urge you to live inspired.
I urge you to find
a way to figure out,
how can I take my job--
how can I take my role
and really inspire
people through it?
And I think I was able to do
that with that little girl.
And I hope that she's able to
do that with her classmates,
and her family, as well.
Now about a year-- ago
almost a year to the date--
it was August of 2017, my father
that gave all of that wisdom
and all of that inspiration to
me and all of those words that
really fueled me--
passed away.
And he went to be with the Lord.
He lived a great life.
He was almost 80 years old.
He was always the
life of the party.
He was someone that always made
people feel great to be around.
That was just the kind
of bubbling personality
that he was.
And as often happens
when you lose a parent--
you really spend most
of your life thinking
about all the ways that you are
different from your parents,
and you want to exert your
independence from your parents.
But let me tell you, when you
have a parent that passes away,
you start thinking about
all the ways that you
are like your parents, and
the influence they had on you,
and the way they mold you,
and the way they shape you,
and the way they transform you.
And I started thinking
about all the things
that my father
wanted me to learn,
and all of the ways that
his ways really inspired
me and helped shape me.
And when he passed, I know that
he became my guardian angel.
I know that he's here today.
I know that many of you may
have guardian angels that
are here today.
And I think if
there's one thing they
want us to know is that we
have such an opportunity.
We have such a great
chance within our jobs,
within our roles, within
our volunteer time,
just within our journeys,
to inspire other people
and to show people that our
challenges and our adversities
aren't in vain--
that we have an opportunity
to learn from them
and grow from them, and to show
a different side of this world.
To show that all of us
can accomplish anything.
Next slide.
That is me working out--
something I need to do more of.
You might even say
determined, inspired,
being a world changer--
this is us.
That's the actor from
"This is Us," by the way.
I met him at a Notre Dame
football game in 2010.
Next slide.
That is me, completing one of
the Rock and Roll Marathons,
where I went from gatecrasher
to actual participant.
And I want you to
know, Googlers,
that if you look at your
life in a different way,
and if you look at your
adversities in a different way,
and if you live your
life with passion,
you live your life
with purpose, and you
live your life with inspiration,
I'll put it like this--
if a young man can come
from Medellin, Colombia
and come into this country
and make his dreams come true,
and write four books, have
a fifth one on the way,
and do a couple of
marathons, and be
able to achieve his
wildest dreams--
why can't you?
Why can't you?
Live with purpose,
live with inspiration,
and know that you
can do anything.
Thank you for your time.
[APPLAUSE]
Do we have time for questions?
Are there any questions in
the house, or any thoughts?
That's a great question.
Do I have bucket list, and
what are the top two or three?
So it's actually kind
of a two part question.
I'm 44.
And right before I turned
40 is when I actually
created a bucket list,
but with a twist.
I made a list of 50 things that
I want to accomplish before 50.
And the reason for that is, they
say that first of all, any goal
that you write down--
any goal that you have, you are
80% more likely to achieve it
if you write it down.
And then the second thing is, if
you create goals that are just
kind of long-term and
just kind of vague,
you might not ever get to it.
But if you give yourself
an exact time window,
you're more apt to
really work on it.
So I specifically
wanted that parameter.
I specifically wanted age 50
to kind of be my cut off age.
Because, I mean, at 50
we're still very young.
But it's only 10 years away.
And so I knew I
was going to work
hard to really get those things
accomplished within the age 50.
And they're pretty
much a lot of the goals
that most people will have--
places they want to see,
things they want to do.
For me, it entailed
I wanted to make sure
that I wrote more books, that
I got to do more travel--
things like that.
But my other kind
of main list that
was kind of an
offshoot of that, is
I have a goal of
speaking in 100 cities.
For me, that also helps take
care of seeing the world,
connecting with old friends and
connecting with people that I
love, experiencing new
adventures and new things
within my journeys.
So 100 cities-- and right now
I am currently at city 53.
So I have 47 more cities
to reach that goal.
And on social media I
made this a hashtag--
#100cities.
So that's my goal and my purpose
that drives me every day,
is how can I find a way to
speak and deliver my message
in as many cities as possible.
So if any of you have ideas
or recommendations or leads,
I'm all ears.
But that's good that
you were thinking
in terms of those terms,
as creating a list
to be able to live inspired.
Other questions?
Yep.
So I've published
four books so far.
The first one is
"Swinging for the Fences."
And that's really the story
of overcoming my disability
and immigrating to the US.
Second book is called
"The Finish Line."
And that was
specifically about doing
the marathon, and what it
took as a triple amputee
to do the marathon.
Third book is called
"See the Good."
And it's all about my
theory that in life,
if you take something bad
that has happened to you
or taken adversity
within your life--
then if you look, you can find
a minimum of two good things
within every bad thing.
So in other words, out of
every piece of adversity,
out of every challenge,
of every confrontation,
out of every bad thing--
minimum, two good things
have come out of it.
You just got to look.
You just got to look and
look for what they are.
And then I actually
have written-- so those
are three motivational books.
Fourth is just a fiction
novel called "Wolf Pack."
And it's about kind of a take
on the old hangover motif, where
he says, this is my wolf pack.
It's a group of friends that
faced adversity together,
and how they do
so as a wolf pack.
And then again, my fifth
one coming out this year,
called, "Living
Inspired," which is
changing your life by choosing
only things that inspire you.
So thank you for asking.
Thank you for coming.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you, Google.